foreign
[Music]
homes she's a detective looks like she
blow over in the wind and she discovered
something that powerful people want to
hide and it's deadly
Sherlock why are you here is it my case
of your own both seems our cases are
connected the game has had its feet
again
extortion blackmail corruption I fear
she's tackled with the wrong people
gosh girls like you don't belong in this
fight hot or not one thing I am good at
is fighting she likes cause in trouble
doesn't she don't be so desperate to
prove yourself anola but it's important
I know what that's like to feel alone to
be ignored no
no
girls
but I think I've made things worse
nonsense
find your allies work with them and you
will become more of who you are stop
that you could be
magnificent
I need your help be my girl well don't
make me repeat it may I come in
everyone here is playing art
x marks a spot testing each other
well let's just move
shouldn't you be in finishing school oh
I wonder who taught you to fight like
that
another thing our mother has to answer
for
[Music]